i have uh i have a bone to pick with you
dave because you did the thing that i
wanted to do if i ever interviewed trump
which was what i'm wondering if you can
pick it out my dad no
the dad was a beautiful moment that
would be but you were going to do that
too though you're going to call dave's
dad yeah
your dad hated trump no
what did i do that was the first thing
that opened ollie g
i always said i was like if i ever talk
to trump the first thing i'll say is
i'll bring up the leg thing because as
far as i remember the only person he's
the only one that that saw through it
got up it also
so when i did that interview with him he
really didn't know who i was like yeah
donald jr was a fan everybody there was
like bar still people but that that
disarmed him actually i don't he was
like oh this is a friendly fire and it
changed his demeanor into you yeah yeah
started explaining it to you yeah and
like
it was crazy because he obviously people
like to get complimented but he found
something that nobody else complimented
him on but he was proud of yeah he loved
it he loved it it changed the entire
actually because
one thing about him
he for sure a little bit probably
similar to me and a lot of people but
when he
his his hackles go up i think he's being
attacked so if he views somebody as like
this guy's an enemy yeah he's he's
basically a real prick back and that's
how a lot of his conflict is but if he
if he thinks you're on his side he turns
into kind of a normal day and then you
asked him
the wildest question to follow up so
you're like yeah i love you you're great
we're awesome why can't people take a
knee
i was like what the [ __ ] is that and
then you is the first time i've ever
interviewed somebody so i don't think he
knew what to think in the moment yeah it
was he was so flattered i i actually got
him and it may still be
the only one to admit he made a mistake
yeah with tweeting well i was like dude
i was like do you ever i'm like you're
going nuts on twitter yeah and i'm like
do you ever just wake up the next day be
like man i wish
he's like yeah i do yeah and as far as i
know he's never admitted that he made a
mistake in his life except that so yeah
yeah did you have other questions you
want to ask him that you did no so so
the thing with that interview is uh i
found out about it like
i don't know less than 24 hours before
like i was on vacation um and somebody
on my team just like hey trump wants you
to come interview him in the rose garden
and i we i've said this people obviously
can t agree disagree i'm like we try not
to be political we because you're gonna
piss somebody off and we're not like
it's the old michael jordan quote like
you know republicans buy sneakers
yeah they're just trying to make money
[Laughter]
i found out really short notice and i
really had never interviewed anybody and
we had a couple of our team go
and hit the trump people are like you
can ask anything anything anything
anything um
and and we go and first of all it's
crazy like mariano rivera was there it
was i think opening day uh it was all
that in
they're being super nice and then right
up to the interview all my guys couldn't
come close and like 30 of his guys
surround us and right before it started
they came up like don't ask about this
this this i just kind of ignored it i
got most of my questions out like people
who like trump are like what a great
interview people don't like trump it's
like you were doing softballs it's like
i don't know nothing about politics it's
like how deep can i get first question
was a hard ball yeah yeah but it was the
compliment man yeah yeah so it was
surreal uh i'd never been to the white
house the whole white house kind of mid
or what no i liked it really yeah i'm
like one of those weird like history how
old are you 38. you're using mid huh
thank you
thank you that's crazy no
we've actually been trying to work on
his vernacular we've been trying to
praise him
why is he crazy
means like not good somebody came up to
me and said it the other day
i didn't expect to hear but it was like
a teenager it was a teenager yeah
but you use it right like you buy shorts
or like no no
yeah yeah
yeah i guess
i use it like where is it's in the
middle no
not that way no i i'm uh uh
i like the white house
no no but it's pretty lit like
[Applause]
you